calculus of exponential functions is
both one of the easiest things to wrap
your head around and also one of the
most important because later on one of
the important applications of this kind
of calculus is in exponential growth and
decay lots and lots of objects like say
populations or radioactive substances
are modeled by this exponential function
so this becomes really important
practically later on but as we pointed
out it's also really easy the derivative
of EDX is of course just e to the X now
we haven't really talked about very much
though some of the questions may have
touched on it every time you learn
something about differentiation that
tells you something about integration
right because they are reverse processes
so if the derivative of e to the X is e
to the X it stands to reason that the
integral stopped three of you why are
you here this time do you have a good
reason hurry up and take a seat you two
am I
I wouldn't like to say it again but it
sounds like I must it will not get any
easier to wake up at this time it will
only get harder so if you are doing
something or controlling your
circumstances in a way that makes it
hard for you to get to this class on
time that thing needs to change if you
have a legitimate reason why you cannot
do that then come and tell me that's
fine some people already have but if you
do not then change something now because
you do not want me to have this
five-minute conversation with you every
period zero four times a cycle it's not
fun and it's a waste of time
are we clear your top sorry let me ask
you in are we clear year twelve okay
where were we we know something about
derivatives that tells you something
about integrals we saw questions that
said differentiate then integrate right
so we know these processes are linked
together if I integrate from here I
should come back to where I started
right this should be just e to the X
with one subtle difference of course
this is an indefinite integral so it
could have come from any of these guys
right where C is any kind of constant
that we like you're just moving the
graph up and down the gradient function
will not be changed okay so this is all
phone we also looked very briefly at
what happens when you don't have the
nice the natural base of e if you had
say 2 to the X it's just off by a
constant in that case of you log 2 it
just depends on the base ok now just
like every time you think of
differentiation you learn something
about integration every time you learn
something about these Exponential's you
learn something about logs because they
have this the same object looked at from
two different sides ok Exponential's and
logs tell you something all about growth
so the natural question that leads out
of this after whatever derivative of EDX
is what is the derivative of the natural
log of X we're going to start with the
natural log because as you can see
everything is nice and meet with the
natural base of e
here's an important time to remind you
that notation with logs not the greatest
L n stands for log natural it's the base
of a so this is the same as log base e
of X okay it pretty much every context
mathematically that's interesting this
is the base we are interested in so much
so that if you're in a textbook or in an
exam or in pretty much any mathematical
literature of any kind if you just see
log of X without any base described they
mean e because that's the one where all
of the nice neat mathematics happens
anywhere mathematically you'll see that
base E except there's another place that
you use logs that is not mathematical
and it sounds ridiculous where that's
not what it means because let's see if
I've got in my front pocket I think I do
because pretty much everyone should have
yeah wonderful they're calculated with
them right you calculate if you don't
have it out just get it out now this is
what I mean by not great your calculator
has to log buttons see log buttons one
says Ln so that's completely unambiguous
we know what that means the N stands for
natural it's base eight okay one of the
ways you can tell that it's base is if
you have a look above the Ln button you
can see it says e to the power of
whatever right at least if you have the
same calculators I do which the vast
majority of you do but then right beside
it there's a button which says just log
and there's no base described and
everything else in this context would
think all that should be base E right
except that it's not because this is not
a mathematical calculator you're like
what other kind of calculator is there
what can you see at that one one doesn't
even say it anymore
used to say at the top this is a
scientific calculator isn't it right and
scientists are not so much interested in
base a what scientific notation in base
like four point seven times ten to the
whatever right because we live in a
decimal system okay
so scientists use base 10 all the time
which is why if you have a look again at
the log button you can see right above
it it does not say e to the power of it
says mine says 10 to power
right so that's a visual cue just for
the sake of interest if you go all the
way the bottom of your calculator next
to the decimal point or mind you notice
there's a times 10 to the X again it's
because it's a scientific calculator
that's the base they're interested in
okay so everywhere in the universe
except your calculator which you use
every day if you see log and there's no
number
it means base 8 bless you okay and all
of these other ways but when you use
this sky you need to get used to tapping
the Ln button and not using the log
button for base eight does that make
sense
is it clear so I'm just gonna add that
as an extra thing Ln log base E log it
means base E except on your calculator
which is mildly frustrating but now that
we've made such a big deal of it and
your calculator itself is so many clues
to remind you hopefully you'll remember
this from now on okay